salut tout le monde je vous fais cette
vidéo pour vous annoncer que les leçons
sur czech comme en français sont sortis
en tout cas les 125 première d'entre
elles c'est moi qui ai traduit les
vidéos et qui les a adaptés en français
il ya aussi des gens qui travaillent
pour chasse comme et qui se sont occupés
de traduire le texte dont quoi on les en
remercie aussi j'en profite pour les
remercier ceux qui qui vous met tout ce
que tout ce que vous lisez en français
sur 13 points comme et on va tout de
suite regardé ce qu'il en est et
regarder une petite vidéo pour avoir un
exemple de ce que de ce à quoi vous
pourrez avoir accès si vous prenez un
abonnement premium sur che scop donc on
va voir
tout d'abord les offres de chasse comme
pour avoir qu'avec les l'abonnement or
en ce qui concerne les leçons vous
n'aurez que les leçons débutants pour
pas que vous fassiez piégé entre
guillemets si vous prenez le platine
vous aurez les leçons jusqu'à jusqu'au
niveau intermédiaire et il n'y a que
l'abonnement diamant donc qui vous offre
toutes les vidéos toutes les vidéos
valent pour avoir accès à absolument
tout ce qui peut y avoir sur check point
com et on va regarder ensemble
à quoi ça ressemble donc pour y avoir
accès je suis là sur mon check point
comme je les ai mis en français oui
j'écris des choses en français moi j'ai
les deux ans en fait français anglais
pour voir un peu ce qui se passe de
partout où je vais aller dans
donc apprendre puis sur la gauche dans
le son donc je clique sur le son eh ben
on va aller en regarder une ensemble
donc on va aller à dans les leçons plus
avancé et on va aller dans les finales
avant c'est justement parce que j'aime
bien les finales donc ça me fait plaisir
de faire une finale avancé je vais
cliquez dessus alors il y en a
quelques-unes et nous on va aller voir
les exemples parce que c'est un thème
tactique intéressant et que ça vous
permettra d'apprendre quelque chose en
regardant cette vidéo de présentation
donc je vais la mettre je vais la lance
et je vais disparaître de l'écran je
vais vous laisser la regarder et on sera
les petits exercices ensemble par la
suite aux échecs il arrive qu absolument
tous les coûts légaux qui sont à votre
disposition soit mauvais et vous
entraîne à votre perte
quand cela arrive vous aimeriez pouvoir
passer votre tour mais aux échecs c'est
interdit vous êtes obligés de jouer un
coup lorsqu'un joueur détériore
grandement sa position en jouant un coup
alors que cela aurait été bien meilleur
de passer son tour
s'ils le pouvaient on appelle cela un
zouk gangs dans cette position le joueur
ayant le trait est à zoug langue ici
avec le très haut blanc il n'y a aucun
coût permettant au roi de garder la
protection du pion g4 remarquer que la
case f4 et protégés
les blancs doivent donner le pion en
jouant roi de 4 et après trois projets 4
les noirs gagneront la partie s'il se
rappelle bien de leur finale de pions
revenons à la position de départ
avec le très haut noir
les noirs ont exactement le même
problème
tous les coûts légaux perdre le pion g5
après 3 g iii les blancs vont prendre le
pion g5 et gagner la partie
regardons un autre exemple
dans cette position
de rester dans le coin pour bloquer la
promotion du pion h mais s'il est noir
tentent de créer un pion passé par b5
alors les blancs gagnerons car après la
prise en b 5 leurs pions ne sera qu'à
trois cases de dames sur échec alors que
le pion noir 1 à 5 est à 4 cases
le plan noir c'est de simplement faire
des allers-retours avec le roi
pouvez vous trouver une manière pour les
blancs de mettre les noirs en zigzag
si vous avez trouvé h7
bien joué ce n'est pas pat car les noirs
ont encore un coup légal
même si ce coût est très mauvais les
noirs n'ont pas d'autre choix que de
jouer b5 et après apprend des cinq les
noirs vont perdre la course de pions
et avec elle la partie après
quatre des six
à 3,17
à deux et des huit dames échec et mat
regardons ensemble un autre exemple
gagner une finale tour contrefout peut
être très difficile voire impossible
suivant où est placé le roi du joueur
avec le fou
dans cette position le roi blanc est
bloqué sur une bande de l'échiquier et
après tour h un échec
le seul coût blanc pour stopper l'échec
est fou c'est un
avec l'aide d'un zoom grand angle pouvez
vous trouver un match en deux pour les
noirs si vous avez trouvé n'importe quel
coût de tours sur la première rangée
bien joué après par exemple tour g1
le roi blanc est obligé de quitter la
protection du fou paroisse à et
maintenant les noirs font matt partout
reprend c'est un échec et mat
regardons maintenant la position de zoug
exemple peut être la plus connue aux
échecs de tous les temps
cette position est tiré de la partie que
l'on appelle l'immortel du zouk gang qui
a opposé frédéric sa niche avec les
blancs à aaron niveau beach avec les
noirs ici les noirs ont un grand
avantage des espaces et toutes leurs
pièces sont bien plus active remarquer
que la dame blanche est presque enfermé
après tours 5e 3 fou prend à f3
pourpre en f3 et maintenant les blancs
encore une casse pour la dame avec dame
g5 nîmes dovic ne voulait pas rentrer
dans cette position et a trouvé une
manière bien plus forte de continuer
li movie cha joué le coup très
tranquille mais très fort h 6 à première
vue ce coût est inoffensif mais en
réalité les blancs sont en langue
à présent les noirs menace tours 5 f3 en
fermant la dame blanche
si les blancs veulent donner de l'espace
à la dame pour se replier ils vont
perdre sur le champ
par exemple si les blancs jouent leur
fou de cases noires sur la seule case
libre pour lui par fou c'est un les
blancs perdre le cavalier b1 après fou
prend bien
remarquez aussi que le cavalier p1 et le
fou j'ai deux n'ont pas de coût possible
sous peine d'être mangés
si les blancs jouent leur tour eu un
disons en c1 alors la case e 2 n'est
plus protégé par la tour et les noirs
gagne la dame
après tours 2
si les blancs jouent leurs hôtes retour
sur la seule case libre f1 alors les
noirs la gagne par fou prend f1 sur tous
les autres coûts les blancs perdront
leurs dames après tour 5 f3
pouvant sauver sa dame ses miches a donc
décidé d'abandonner ici
adversaire en 12 langues
donc j'espère que cette petite vidéo
vous a plu et shell est évident que ma
voix n'était pas trop robotique mais bon
c'est à l'exercice qui demandait ça on
va justement en parlant d' exercice
passé aux exo en lançant les défis donc
on va avoir quelques petits exercices à
faire ici c'est très haut blanc les deux
rois c# autour des derniers pions de jeu
parviendrez-vous à mettre votre
adversaire en exemple alors on va
essayer si je fais 3 e 4 c'est lui qui
va faire rage et 3 il va mettre en
exergue donc je vais faire roi e5 je
vais attaquer son pion il fait roi g3 on
dit que c'est une bonne décision
excellente décision et roy e 4 3 g20
après quatre mois j'ai gagné deux pions
ça gagne l'exercice à l'on va passer au
suivant
ma tête cache un petit peu alors ici
c'est très haut blanc il ya une bataille
autour du pion f4 faut que je m en
zigzag si je pousse à 4 il va faire à 5
ça va pas être cool je vais faire à
trois il va faire à cinq je vais faire à
4 il va faire froid f2 et bim je vais
lui prendre son pion c'est gagner ici ou
là là c'est plus compliqué très haut
noir trouver une combinaison trois coups
forçant le match grâce au thème de zoug
yang alors son seul coup ce serait de
jouer g4 avec les blancs et après j'ai
cinq si j'ai réussi à faire alger et que
mon roi protège ce sera ma tu donc je
vais faire web 3g 4 3 f 4g 5
hg et c'est gagné allez on va faire le
suivant ici c'est très haut blanc c'est
dans cette célèbre étude du maître
américain paul murphy trouver le superbe
coup forçant le mât temps de grâce aux
objets en bon celui-là il est connu je
vais pas faire semblant ne pas le savoir
c'est tour à 6 puis on prend à 6 et
bessette maths c'est un zouk gang et on
va se faire le dernier ici c'est très
haut blanc je vois que le roi est un
petit peu bloquée dans ce coin-là le
deux contre un allèle roi il est en ma
faveur puisque les pions sont bloqués je
vais commencer par à 6 il va être obligé
de pousser leurs pions et je vais filer
à dame
et j'ai gagné j'ai fait j'ai pris des
trois coureurs et donc voilà les leçons
vous en démontrer une j'ai fait les
exercices avec vous si vous avez la
botte de leur opposer comme le g1 lui
sont d'après ses synthés la survie de
leur vie en rose et donc la vidéo à la
démarre en même temps entendez par les
deux fois c'est à inception
bon bah écoute et j'espère que ça vous a
plus que ce qu'ils pourront profiter des
leçons en feront des bons retours et
qu'ils seront très heureux de tout et on
se retrouve très bientôt sur ciao ciao
ciao